I'm not the kind of man
who does things
the conventional way.
When I get jury duty,
I say I'm sick.
And when I pay my taxes,
I do not pay my taxes.
(laughter)
That's why I was so happy
about Tuesday's primary results.
It was wall-to-wall victories
for outsider candidates,
those brave politicians
well beyond the mainstream
who don't know the meaning
of "bipartisan"
or most other words.
(laughter)
Opposers, let's look
at some of these new names
in the political arena.
Welcome to Fringe Watch 2018.
Too fringe,
too far to the extreme.
Fringe and extreme-- that's
kind of mainstream America now.
(distorted):
Fringe...
(braying, trumpeting)
(rattling, grunting, chirping)
-(cheering, applause)
-Whoa! Whoa!
That gorilla's actually running
for Topeka comptroller.
(laughter)
Opposers, we're here to salute
the fringe candidates,
those antiestablishment beasts
climbing into the ring
that is American politics.
First up, weighing in
at zero legislative experience,
he's a candidate
for Nevada's state legislature--
Dennis Hof.
-(bell clangs)
-No.
Nevada voters just nominated Hof
as the GOP contender,
and it's easy to see why--
he has a nuanced,
comprehensive fiscal policy
known as being...
A pimp who calls himself
"The Trump of Pahrump"
wins the Republican primary for
the Nevada state legislature.
Dennis Hof,
who owns several brothels
in the state and stars
in the HBO reality series,
Cathouse, takes pride
in emulating Donald Trump,
even writing a book called
The Art of the Pimp.
-Oh-ho!
-(laughter)
The Art of the Pimp.
It's like The Art of the Deal,
but slightly more
respectful to women.
-(laughter, whooping)
-Uh...
Yes. Just a little bit.
I love Hof.
Just watch
this Republican nominee at work.
Want me to walk you around
and show you everything?
-Yeah, yeah.
-There's just rooms down here,
and the girls decorate them
like they want.
Yeah, we want people
to be comfortable.
LED plasma TVs.
Yeah, it looks just like
a regular bedroom.
-What is this?
-This is a swing.
I don't quite know, um...
how this works.
(audience groans)
Incidentally, "I don't know,
um, how this works"
is also Hof's campaign slogan.
(laughter)
Still, the question
on everyone's mind is:
Can a candidate who treats
women's bodies as commodities
fit in with today's GOP?
(laughter)
Yes.
Because Hof is all in on Trump.
When describing how the
president inspired him to run,
Hof said Trump "found the way
and I jumped on it."
And that Donald Trump was
"the Christopher Columbus."
Yeah. Trump and Columbus
are the same.
Brave pioneers who know
that to achieve greatness,
sometimes you've got to evict
the current residents.
So, we've got a pimp who
idolizes a former reality host
running to make laws for a state
where you can contract syphilis
just by flying over it.
(laughter)
That's some good fringe.
But like I told my tailor,
I think we can go even fringier.
(laughter)
Yeah, that wasn't enough.
Stepping into the ring now,
standing at a towering
six foot "I will ruin
your family's Thanksgiving,"
it's the winner of Virginia's
Republican Senate primary,
-Corey Stewart.
-(bell clangs)
Yes, now, this hunk of red meat
crushed his mainstream opponents
in the primary.
So of course, the CNN-dinistas
are complaining about him.
Stewart is known
for his championing
of Confederate symbols
and his ties
to several unrepentant bigots,
including organizers
and participants in the
Charlottesville rally last year.
Oh, okay.
That's a big charge.
It's not his fault
he's getting support
from the tiki torch
and khaki coalition.
(laughter)
They support lots of Republicans
for some reason.
And what's Stewart supposed
to do about it?
Spit in the face
of his supporters?
He can't.
They're wearing hoods.
(laughter, groans)
I mean, come on.
Stewart can't be that bad a guy.
In fact, President Trump
endorsed Stewart,
saying that he has
a good chance at winning.
Let me show you how unfairly
Stewart's being treated.
Last year,
he praised Paul Nehlen,
a self-professed
"pro-white" candidate,
for Congress
as his "personal hero."
Now, is Paul Nehlen
a white supremacist?
Technically, definitely.
But Stewart has since
disavowed Nehlen,
which explains
the old expression:
never meet your heroes...
especially if all your heroes
are white supremacists.
Okay, the ring is filled
to the brim with fringe.
But, my God.
What's this?
We have an unexpected challenger
entering the ring?
-And it's a Democrat.
-(bell rings)
Okay, wow. Okay.
Opposers, normally Fringewatch
is just for the right.
But once in a while,
a liberal breaks through
and earns their stripes.
I present to you Colorado
congressional hopeful,
Levi Tillemann.
I'm Levi Tillemann.
I'm calling on congress to stop
talking past each other
and try something new.
Empower schools and teachers
with non-lethal
self-defense tools,
like this can of pepper spray.
(laughter)
(gasps)
It's incredibly painful.
It's just unbearable.
It's like lava in your eyes.
(laughing)
Now, that's my kind of Democrat.
(laughter)
The kind who will pepper spray
a Democrat.
All right,
so I gather Levi was trying
to promote non-gun solutions
to school violence.
And, obviously, I hate that,
because the only real answer
is "good guy with a gun,"
et cetera.
But I've got to see more
of this guy.
I don't care if he's
progressive.
I love watching Democrats
shoot themselves in the foot,
and Levi seems like he might
actually do that.
So, Levi, buddy, I can't wait
for you to promote
a higher minimum wage
by clamping mousetraps
on your nipples,
or...
fight for immigration reform
by locking yourself in a
Saw-style trap
where the key is surgically
implanted behind your left eye.
I mean, I'm excited about
the new direction
of the Democratic party.
And that direction?
Careening into the Grand Canyon,
attempting to make a point about
corporate personhood.
These leaders are inspiring,
but you know what?
We can do fringer.
That's why... I'm calling
on you, at home,
-to take on the mainstream.
-(patriotic music plays)
Are you an unlicensed
sea captain living on a boat
that we could gerrymander
into a state?
Join us.
Are you the last living
Civil War general
who is somehow still alive?
Saddle up, partner.
Are you a Bible that bumped into
a genie's lamp
and gained the power of speech?
Well, welcome aboard.
Get out there, Opposers.
Way, way the (bleep) out there.